[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right fan corrections this of course
is a segment where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show as if that were
possible
[Laughter]
far hundreds of challengers not one
winner not one well tonight a fan named
matt from cleveland thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened when i was
talking recently about the pope retiring
hey conan matt from cleveland here i was
watching your uh wednesday episode and
you were talking about the pope retiring
and with him retiring the destruction of
his ring pope benedict has revealed that
after he steps down he will destroy his
papal ring that's what he said
yeah in keeping with vatican law he will
destroy the ring by casting it back into
the fires of mordor
you said that he would go and destroy it
in mordor
well here to tell you you're incorrect a
few things wrong about this
first thing is
one doesn't simply walk into mordor
that's boring he knows he's been around
for a while and second even if he did
get into mordor he would have to take it
and cast it to the fiery pits of mount
do
gandalf he's been there he knows awesome
so you see why this is an issue him
being a pope he's never gonna make it
past the black gate and get into mordor
no way
it's not gonna happen
so
let's see how you talk your way out of
this one mr fans pants
and go
that was chilling
well
matt from cleveland i've got some very
bad news for you
you're wrong and since you clearly enjoy
dolls and action figures
we've decided to explain to you why
you're wrong in a way that you can
understand
enjoy
fan correction theater presents matt in
cleveland matt are you down there
mom
don't come down i need you to go buy me
cigarettes not now mom i'm busy you
better not be making a fan correction
about walking in the mordor cause you'd
be dead wrong that's how frodo and sam
got in there you idiot i hate you mom
don't talk to me that way in front of my
new boyfriend
hey baby
yes loki let's go and leave my son down
there making dumb fan correction videos
you'll be sorry when conan admits he was
wrong and says i'm too cool to make fun
of i'm matt from cleveland i'm matt from
cleveland
i'm matt from cleveland
[Applause]
well
the challenge still stands if you think
you've spotted an error on our show
reported at teamcoco.com haha i found an
ever we will sort it out right here on
the air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make chump meat out of the
maestro